i'm jason chaffetz i'm katie pavlich i'm
steve ducey and this is the fox news
rundown
tuesday march 22nd 2022 i'm john saucier
27 days later and this russian invasion
of ukraine continues is that longer or
shorter than you thought it would last
early on in this conflict many experts
predicted this would be a swift russian
victory but ukraine has proven to be
strong in the resolve to maintain
freedom ukraine is doing such a good job
against a
premier army using just these close-in
weapons it's incredibly brave incredibly
bold and it means they have some really
good intelligence and surveillance and
reconnaissance and that home field
advantage of fighting for their own
cities this is the fox news rundown war
on ukraine
[Music]
this has been a rather bloody rather
long and rather clunky russian invasion
of ukraine and the reality is millions
of people's lives have been interrupted
the predictions russia would easily
march through ukraine have proven to be
wrong
day 27 and russia has not achieved any
of their objectives we're speaking today
with fox news contributor dr rebecca
grant an expert on national security and
military affairs she's been following
all of this very closely and ukraine has
won world support they've won a couple
of small important engagements including
a little battle outside kiev today
and i think ukraine can win as long as
we keep the armed supplies coming into
them now by arm supplies you're talking
about anti-tank weaponry anti-aircraft
weaponry that the united states and
other nato powers have supplied although
the president of ukraine vladimir
zelinsky he's repeatedly calling for a
no-fly zone to be set up do you really
think the ukrainians even need that
right now because so far russia has not
been able to maintain any sort of air
superiority over ukraine
on the no-fly zone it's frustrating
because two or three weeks ago a no-fly
zone would have put a lid on this whole
war and stopped russian maneuver i can
understand why zolensky wanted the clear
skies
over ukraine it also would have cut down
on the russian air force's ability to
bomb the cities you know at this point
the way the battle is unfolding we've
decided to give ukraine weapons to fight
up close they're good weapons but they
all require ukraine's forces to get real
close to the russians the javelin
anti-tank missile is super but it's got
about a two mile range similarly the
stingers which are used for air defense
great weapon but again you have to
really see that helicopter or aircraft
or cruise missile coming through to be
able to use the stinger what's amazing
to me is that ukraine is doing such a
good job against a premier army using
just these close-in weapons it's
incredibly brave incredibly bold and it
means they have some really good
intelligence and surveillance and
reconnaissance and that home field
advantage of fighting for their own
cities yeah indeed the home field
advantage is a huge thing one question
really that's been on my mind during
this conflict though regarding the
western weapons that have been shipped
into ukraine with your analysis do you
think that russia would have been able
to topple ukraine more quickly if none
of those weapons had ever been sent in
oh no question and it goes back to the
training that the us and britain and
canada and other nato allies provided to
ukraine starting back in 2014 and 2015
and then the lethal weapons like the
javelin that were provided starting
under the trump administration and biden
continued that so with those weapons and
that training ukraine has really been
able to
pick off you know the lead tank in the
russian column they've been able to hit
supply vehicles you know hidden out in
the forest and that's been enough to
really
surprise and unravel the immediate
russian drive around those cities that's
what's working
yeah indeed well there is one weapon
that the ukraine wants that the west has
not provided so far and those are
fighter jets specifically the soviet-era
mig fighter jets that poland says
they're happy to transfer to ukraine for
use by their pilots possibly through
ramstein air base there in germany
how big is the lack of those polish migs
playing into this war do you think
i wish those migs were in ukraine right
now you know for two reasons one because
zielinski requested them and the migs
would help ukraine fly a bit more
the other reason honestly is because
poland deserves it poland is under
incredible pressure with the border with
ukraine and belarus and taking in you
know now two million refugees so i think
poland deserved to get its migs
transferred and to be back filled with
newer f-16 and f-35 fighters from the
u.s you know the pentagon's point was
that they thought ukraine was doing okay
with other types of weapons all right
maybe that's a fair military judgment
but i think just for morale purposes
alone those migs should have gone to
zolensky we're speaking today with fox
news contributor dr rebecca grant she is
an expert on a number of things but
specifically aerospace is your big area
of expertise and so you know a lot about
these polish migs and why in particular
is this aircraft able to give ukraine
some sort of advantage if they were able
to get it
the key is that uh ukraine's air force
already operates the mig-29 now these
migs are old okay right poland had
upgraded them so that would have given
them more aircraft and the ability
perhaps to do some air-to-ground attack
you see those pictures when the javelins
attack a russian tank column on the
highway well imagine what a really
capable
air force could do to that so with those
mig-29s ukraine would have had more
option to attack the russian forces as
they tried to move around and encircle
cities still very dangerous but they
might have been able to make more
progress instead what they're doing now
is relying just on a ground to ground
attack
today we're on the air with an expert on
the air dr rebecca grant fox news
contributor and president of iris
independent research a small women-owned
business specializing in defense and
aerospace research and consulting for
corporate and government clients she
also appears with us quite often we'll
have more coming up on the other side of
this
early on in this war russian president
vladimir putin advised the russian
forces to be on high nuclear alert that
kind of rhetoric toned down a little bit
but again this war is dragged on 27 days
as you mentioned there in the open and
now again we're hearing about nuclear
weapons now obviously god forbid
anything like that ever happens but do
you think there is a possibility in this
situation here where ukraine has really
embarrassed russia on a world stage uh
large country not able to take over a
small country they've got about 10th of
the military ukraine does than russia do
you think there's any possibility that
putin might just change a strategy and
and bring nuclear weapons into the fight
here
i expect putin to threaten with all his
terror weapons that's the hypersonic
missiles
cyber attack
chemical weapons and maybe even tactical
nuclear weapons but the point
of those threats is to try to keep the
us and nato backed off and try to make
sure that we don't send more military
assistance to ukraine it's not in
putin's interest to use a nuclear weapon
in ukraine hey remember he says he's
trying to liberate the place he thinks
it's part of russia so no reason to use
a tactical nuclear weapon there or
chemical weapons but i expect to see a
lot of threats nato and the us are going
to have to have a really stiff backbone
to resist that and face him down yeah
that's interesting that putin says
ukraine's part of russia you wouldn't
think so by the way he's treated the
city of mariopol it's southern port city
that russia wanted really badly they've
been unable to capture it there's a big
city of hundreds of thousands of people
in there many can't get out and the
latest reports that were mary opal is
completely destroyed at this point so
are you seeing a possible shift in
strategy by putin if he can't take
ukraine to destroy it because that's
what he's done with this city sadly
we've seen him do that in other places
like grozny and aleppo
so he has shifted to using firepower to
try to put enough pressure on the
zielinski government to collapse you
know we know ukraine is not going to
give in to that but i expect to see more
firepower
aimed at those cities unfortunately and
that's because the maneuver has stalled
there was a really important let me
mention a little engagement that took
place
west of kiev today when the ukraine's
forces pushed back the russians from a
little town called macquarie but it's
important because it's about a mile from
the big highway that goes out to the
west it's a key supply route from
western ukraine into kiev and for
ukraine to be able to counter attack
there shows you that russian forces are
really stopped on the ground sadly that
does mean we're going to see probably
more firepower that is putin's style
it's brutal it's a war crime i expect to
see more of it
yeah indeed let's talk about the city of
kiev because obviously russia hasn't
been able to take it you just said
ukrainian forces are now repelling the
russians from some of the suburbs
outside some of the thought here was
that russia was going to slowly encircle
the capital city and then do an all-out
assault and try and invade and take the
capital they haven't been able to do
that and i think a lot of that is due to
the leadership of the president of
ukraine vladimir zelinski he's been very
public especially on social media with
the fact that he's still there in the
capitol working every day how do you
feel about how this wartime president
he's been thrust into this has performed
during what is a war
zielinski is an absolute hero and yes
putin wanted to catch zolensky take down
the zolensky government or encircle kiev
and he hasn't been able to do any of
that so as long as zelinski and his
government is working there in kyo that
is that is victory for ukraine
vital though that ukraine's armed forces
keep up their counter-attacks
so that the russians can't encircle the
city so far what they haven't been able
to do
is to move south and swing down past the
major highway and cut back up into kiev
they have not been able to do that and
that is a really significant victory for
ukraine if we see kiev hold i think
that's going to be very important now i
will say though that we see a lot of
emphasis on mariupol and it could be
that russia has paused trying to get
marijuana under control
to link to that eastern region before
they try again over
towards kiev all the more reason why
we've got to continue to support ukraine
with the best military supplies and
military intelligence that we can feed
into them as they fight russia we have
got to see putin defeated in russia it's
important to world security yeah indeed
and especially that part of the world a
very volatile area we don't need to talk
about what happened in the 1940s there
and this is really the largest european
war or attack or military incursion
whatever you want to call it since world
war ii now in that conflict it involves
multiple countries i was wondering if
this might as well we haven't talked a
lot about belarus but this could be a
major storyline here this is a country
that is friendly to putin's government
and we saw russian soldiers amassing in
belarus before they went into the
ukraine do you think that country might
step into the fold here and help out
russia and could that be enough to tip
the scales in putin's favor hard to say
belarus has already helped by letting
russia swing down through their
territory
that's how russia was able to start that
march on cube so belarus is basically
part of russia at this point as far as
this war is concerned
and you know you're absolutely right you
know this is this is such a large
conflict and the one thing
that putin really pays attention to
right now is what is happening to his
russian forces on the ground the
pentagon told us today they think that
they're down to about 90 percent
of what went in which tells us there
really is some serious attrition
i believe the one thing that will make
putin get serious about talks is if he
sees the detailed destruction of these
invading russian forces that's what's
going to get his attention
fox news contributor dr rebecca grant
you know a lot about what's going on
there we appreciate your insight
specifically when it comes to the
weaponry how it's used but also where
putin is in all this ever-changing
battle which lingers on we really
appreciate it thank you so much for
taking some time to join us here on the
fox news rundown war on ukraine podcast
thank you and stand with ukraine
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
you